OK, here are two questions that can change your career,...
...your business, maybe even your life.
The first comes from Claire Boothe Luce,...
...one of the first women to serve in the U.S. Congress.
One day in the early 1960s, she went to visit President Kennedy.
And she told him this, "A great man is a sentence."
Abraham Lincoln's sentence was, "He preserved the Union and freed the slaves."
Franklin Roosevelt's sentence was, "He lifted us out of a great depression and helped us win a world war."
Luce worried that Kennedy was trying to do too many things...
...and that his sentence risked becoming a muddled paragraph.
If you really want to find your true motivation, ask yourself that question, "What's my sentence?".
You don't have to be president of anything for this to help.
Maybe your sentence is, "She invented a device that made people's lives easier."
Maybe it's, "He taught two generations of kids how to read."
Think about your sentence, then use it to navigate your life.
But to make your sentence really come alive and to create motivation that lasts,...
...you need a second question.
So, each night before you go to sleep ask yourself, "Was I better today than yesterday?"
Keep asking that question because that's how we really improve.
Day by day, step by step, over and over for a very long time.
It's tough, but it's the only way.
Combine these two questions and motivation...
...at work, in business and the rest of your life....
...will take care of itself.
Drive: The surprising truth about what motivates us.